it's fascinating to me that you and i
are talking about this from very
different perspectives but we're
really talking about the same thing
yeah
totally
it almost
you know one thing that comes to mind is
you know this whole concept of
the you know that we need to ground
literally electrically ground ourselves
because we we collect too much
um
electrical energy and you know it sort
of messes things up
um as one
ploy to
alleviate
the um you know bateson's
um double bind for lack of a better way
of expressing it the neuroses the
psychosis the confusion
about you know means and ends
cause and effect
like that
one of the ways to explain
grounding oneself could also just be
meditation itself
and the act of um meditation has a lot
of
um
[Music]
to to be like properly explained is very
important because
just by like calming the mind or like
the fluctuations of the mind
um which is trying to race
into um these different webs like we
talked about earlier there's like
interdependent webs and concepts and
ideas that is running between
and
we could just think of meditation as the
process of sort of like reeling back
the using the breath as a tool
to reel back the intense proliferation
to a state that is
more
concentrated
focused
calm
and in doing so
there can be a realization
of
who the one
that is speaking
truly is
and who the one that is listening right
now truly is
and how that intelligence
is just with itself
and that is just god or the one
and that that's just as simple as it
gets
and that
upon that realization you sort of
you release your attachment to your
individual identity so much
and you can more easily empty yourself
out of everything that you were trying
to get personally and instead now we can
be more empty for that intelligence to
serve itself
as
this earth wakes up
and um and there's nothing more freeing
than that anyway but so that that
component to this is so important to
know truly what meditation is or to know
truly what the like the cessation of the
mental proliferation what that truly
gives you access to and i feel like that
might be what you're referencing with
this grounding because we know so many
people that are just obsessively
speaking about concepts and ideas and
proliferating about their sense of self
and their sense of self-worth and
creating separation with other people
that are that have that they have no
relation to and so that whole process is
um
it's like a weapon of mass destruction
really
like um the more than nukes
um you could say the largest
um weapon of mass destruction is the
sense of self um
and the sense of separation
um
and so that
if we if we begin looking at it that way
uh we can really quickly heal
earth and heal each other and wake up to
peace
unity prosperity abundance for all
when you no longer see a separation
between you
and other
then it becomes easier to only care
about wanting to meet the basic needs of
the whole world and to have everybody be
swimming in prosperity in abundance why
not
so this is this is where this leads to
yeah
yeah when you talked about brett i used
to be a long distance runner and
uh you know i used to experience that
runner's high but then i could i figured
out how to bring it on deliberately by
just
sinking my breathing to my heart rate to
my the pace i was running at i could i
could bring it on deliberately um
nice yeah yeah but but i think it's
important to understand that all this
because you know i've been exposed to
these kinds of eastern thoughts
for my entire life really but i always
thought of that as separate from what i
think about but now in the realization
that that the physio my physiology is
totally consistent with what you're
talking about i think it's important to
realize it's within us
it's we only have to be able to
realize how it how it functions within
us in order to get everything sort of
you know aligned in a way where now you
are able to interface in an effective
way that may sound trivial but i don't
think it is
and you and i both know they're
most people i don't think are really in
touch with their own physiology
um they don't care to be it's icky
but but if you understand it in a way
so i'm fascinated by the placebo effect
which i'm sure you're aware of because
i'm i'm convinced that once you
understand that you have some pain
somewhere you can direct
your
energies toward that pain and you can
alleviate it totally true
yeah i mean you can do that deliberately
or
better said i think you can figure out
how to do that and and you can become
more and more competent at it in the
same way that you were talking about the
interaction between two people even
within yourself
you can alleviate the dis this
homeostasis the
lack of equilibrium of your physiologic
equilibrium within yourself as a proof
of principle to yourself
and you know and that there is room
there is place obviously for medicine
because
because there are places where it's not
possible
for whatever reason um
and maybe that will become clearer as
people become
practitioners of their own
of taking control of their own
physiology
as best they can
yeah
yeah
lines yeah